LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to "Google
Developers Weekly" for
September 30, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this is our
highlight reel of what's
happening in the world
of Google Developers
on the set and off.
This week, we welcome back the
"Root Access" team, led by Don
Dodge, for a pair of shows
highlighting issues faced by
most every startup
as they grow.
The first show included guest
Izabel Idris, who talked about
how to capture a product's
persona and deliver a great
user interface.
Your product not only
has to be smart
but be smartly designed.
Our second "Root Access" show
is all about ideas.
When you're coming up with your
startup ideas, you might
worry that someone would steal
your idea outright and build
their own competing company.
Don Dodge takes the time to
answer viewer questions and
tell you the inside scoop on his
experience at Napster, the
music-sharing pioneer.
By popular demand, Nasir Khan
returned to our studio to
debut the much-awaited
documentation for the new
Wallet Instant Buy API, helping
you accept payments
for goods and services
in your application.
And if you're among the many
looking to get started with a
cloud platform, this was
your lucky week.
Martin Omander and Alex Maier
connected with Mandy Waite
from London and taught you the
process of how to start over
at zero and end up
with Hello World.
Sticking with the cloud, as we
often do, Nick Bortolotti
delivered the latest from Latam
with a piece focused on
non-rational cloud
data storage.
It is by far the best rundown of
BigQuery and Google Compute
Engine I've ever heard,
in Spanish.
And this week, Jeff Posnick
phoned in from New York City
to demonstrate how you can
discover great videos and
channels using the YouTube
Data API Version 3.
The event was a companion piece
to an introductory blog
post that debuted earlier
this month.
And meanwhile, the Wallet
Developers duo of Mihai
Ionescu and Peng Ying introduced
us to the newly
released Wallet Objects Platform
with special guest
Tania Depasquale, which helps
merchants acquire and engage
loyal customers.
Making the web universally
accessible is a big part of
Google's mission.
David Tseng and Volker Sorge
joined us to once again talk
about ChromeVox, a screen
reader for Chrome.
ChromeVox can now read
all kinds of
mathematics on the web.
As a developer, you will be able
to customize reading of
your own math content and make
your content work for
low-vision users.
Also, recently on GDL, Felipe
Hoffa and Michael Manoochehri
talked to you about
the great new
correlation features in BigQuery.
This talk inspired Googler Josh
Livni from the Maps team
to mash up Maps and BigQuery
data to show airport delays.
Josh generated the data with
Felipe and Michael's code,
then wrote some JavaScript
to build the map.
This powerful correlation can
be used to predict the
likelihood of future delays, so
you know just how close you
can cut it when leaving
for the airport.
Also last week, the Android
Studio team
released version 0.2.10.
Of course, it has some bug fixes
and probably some new
bugs, but you'll also find
improved quick documentation,
integrated traceview,
better layout
rendering, and other goodies.
Be sure to upgrade if
you haven't already.
Security is easy.
You just have to be perfect
every single time.
Those are the words of Mike
West, who gets our attention
with the scary advice in his
talk about how to prevent
cross-site scripting attacks.
Check out Mike's talk
and his slides.
It's a great investment in
making your site safer from
bad things.
In the world of politics,
last week saw the
German federal elections.
And Google developers were there
with an election results
map built in Dart.
Google's Jason Brooks built
the app, noting that Dart
provided great power
and flexibility.
The map displayed results
by district as
well as national totals.
And finally, Andres Leonardo
Martinez Ortiz continues his
series of posts about
entrepreneurship in sunny Spain.
This time, he focuses
on Valencia.
If you're looking for some new
places to explore, check out
all of his posts.
And to make sure you never miss
a single thing from the
world of Google Developers,
subscribe to Google Developers
on YouTube and check out
the GDL schedule at
developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.